question du jour quand doit-on changer
son smartphone avec tous les smartphones
qui sort qui sont tous plus sexy les uns
que les autres
bon rien à d'autres un petit peu moins
mais la plupart des gros smartphone
relations qui sont hyper cool on voit
qu'à des produits qui vont arriver qui
sont hyper hyper hyper intéressant la
question à se poser c'est maintenant
quand doit-on changer son smartphone
est ce qu'on doit changer son smartphone
si oui dans quelles conditions pour au
final ne pas se laisser tenter par un
nouveau produit trop cool parce que ça
ça coûte quand même très cher c'est
l'intérêt de cette vidéo on va regarder
ça et on n'est pas maintenant
alors des smartphones il y en a qui sort
tout le temps apple
huawei honor au pot vivo les uns les
autres et tous y en a de tous les côtés
d'ewan plus ces compagnies fin il y a
tellement de produits
ils ont tous leur particularité il y en
a plein qu'on a envie d'avoir
parce qu'ils ont les trouve hyper sexy
sauf que en réalité in fine et commander
sa cote des pépettes
et ça forcément on peut pas changer de
smartphone tout le temps au final c'est
pas non plus intéressant d'un point de
vue écologique voilà il fait un petit
peu responsables donc quand va-t-on
changer son smartphone pour moi j'ai
vraiment repéré cinq cas qui nous
permettent facilement de changer notre
smartphone alors le tout premier cas le
tout premier le plus logique vous allez
me dire c'est quand votre smartphone il
vient de vous lâcher bien évidemment pas
forcément il faut passer par là votre
smartphone vient de vous lâchez vous
êtes sûr qu'il est mort c'est pas juste
un écran a changé ce n'est pas du tout
une batterie qui n'en peut plus c'est
vraiment un smartphone a changé il s'est
éteint claque on pourra plus jamais
récupéré dans ce cas là gagne évidemment
posez vous la question ensuite des
produits que vous voulez l'utilisation
que vous avez réellement d'un produit
sur la photo sur la vidéo sur la
puissance sur du gainey et appelons là
vous choisissez votre produit sans ne
reparlera plus tard un v6 faire un petit
guide générale pour savoir comment
choisir son smartphone mais là c'est pas
la question
donc effectivement votre smartphone est
morte en charge le cas numéro de ce que
vous avez un besoin réel d'une solution
particulière pour combler un besoin
alors ça peut paraître un peu technique
quand je le dis mais votre smartphone
actuel est intéressant mais vous êtes
vachement limité parce que il ya des
choses que vous souhaitez faire nous
vous pouvez pas faire il veut
smartphones à ce moment là il ya un réel
intérêt de changer pour répondre à un
besoin pas à une envie un besoin
attention parce que l'envié on en a on
se laisse tenter quand on a de nouveaux
smartphones où on garde ce week-end
d'ouverture variables de chez samsung on
regarde des smartphones qui font de la
photo et de la vidéo de façon incroyable
du côté de chez huawei des produits
hyper sexy avec al fayçali du côté de
chez apple
est-ce que vous avez réellement besoin
de ça c'est pas dit si par contre vous
avez un réel besoin par exemple vous
avez un besoin de qualité de photo à
faible luminosité pour du travail vous
avez réellement besoin sont là il ya un
intérêt de vous dire je vais changer mon
smartphone pour aller sur ce produit
pour m'équiper parce que j'en ai un réel
besoin
autre exemple la double carte sim
pendant des années on a eu beaucoup de
smartphones avec une seule carte sim
là il ya plein de smartphones qui sont
arrivés et qu'ils ont continué à arriver
avec des
le coeur de cible les opérateurs lâche
un peu les vans et les choses qui
arrivent de plus en plus même
même apple pourrait s'y mettre c'est
dire donc vous avez un réel besoin vous
avez besoin parce que vous partez
souvent à l'étranger dont vous avez
votre carte sim de votre pays plus la
carte sim de l'autre pays vous avez un
besoin vous êtes étudiant vous habitez
en france vous avez travaillé en italie
je ne sais où vous allez faire vos
études pourquoi pas donc il ya un besoin
d'avoir ces double carte sim dans votre
bécane donc acheté un smartphone avec un
double et heures karting sens un sens ça
vous évite de changer la carte sim à
chaque fois et la guérilla derrière bon
pourquoi pas ça peut s'entendre
vous êtes frontaliers c'est la même
chose pour le business dans une carte
pro d'une carte perso tout ça s'entend
effectivement aller sur un produit qui
vous permet d'avoir tout dans votre
smartphone ça réel intérêt le cas numéro
trois c'est lorsque votre smartphone
n'accepte plus les nouvelles
applications vous ne pouvez plus faire
les mises à jour les smartphones qui ont
un petit peu d'âge ont des os qui sont
forcément un peu datés aussi on peut
faire des mises à jour mais jusqu'à un
certain point
jusqu'à ce que les performances de votre
machine plus l'accepter il arrive que
vous ayez des oev vous ne puissiez plus
mettre à jour et les nouvelles versions
pourtant d'applications nécessite cette
version cette nouvelle version de l'os
et vous ne pouvez pas le faire donc du
coup on est embêté parce qu'on peut pas
voir le dollar stores notre application
on en aurait réellement besoin pour le
travail
on en a réellement besoin pour nos
études ou pour notre vie de tous les
jours là il ya un réel intérêt à se dire
bon smartphone j'arrivais impôts au bout
du bout du bout du bout je leur donnais
le plus loin possible maintenant à
l'ouest je peux plus mettre à jour par
aqpa une nouvelle application
j'ai des vieux trucs sont plus mis à
jour et pourquoi pas l'inde et les
applications qui ne fonctionne plus donc
qu'est-ce que je peux faire qu'est-ce
qu'il faut que je fasse c'est bien ce
moment là la question se pose de changer
son smartphone alors une fois de plus
avant de le changer
regardez bien qu'elle produit va vous
intéresser pour pas se planter parce que
si vous vous plantez vous acheter le
produit pour être embêté devant le
changer très peu de temps après donc
allé voir un produit qui vous permettra
de voir dans le temps de voir quelque
chose qui va durer quand même quelques
années qu'un numéro 4 votre smartphone
ram vous n'en pouvez plus dit maintenant
dingue à ouvrir les applications vous
passez des heures et des heures dessus
c'est une vraie plaie vous en pouvait
plus c'est une vraie galère vous voulez
voir quelque chose paf ça sauve au bout
d'un moment ça plante
bon moi je comprends ça je l'aï déjà
qu'un ipad donc effectivement la
question sur un smartphone se pose
également
quand vous avez une machine qui rament
tellement que vous pouvez plus utiliser
de façon intuitive logica vous avez
besoin
rapidement une application pour
connaître une solution pour un transport
en commun pour réserver un taxi quoi que
ce soit vous pouvez pu le faire votre
machine ram c'est un petit peu au petit
bonheur la chance
à ce moment là on se pose la question de
changer sa machine et c'est franchement
légitime qu'un numéro simple chose qui
m'est aussi arrivé votre machine manque
d espace de stockage
il ya quelques temps j'avais ce truc là
voilà on va vous montrer
j'avais un iphone 5 c 16 giga de
stockage c'est trop peu c'était en tout
cas beaucoup trop peu tout au début
j'avais pas de problème je m'étais
quelques photos quelques vidéos ça
marchait très bien
sauf qu arrive un moment les
applications les messages tout prenait
énormément de place j'ai vu par moi même
supprimer des messages supprimer toutes
les photos toutes ma musique ne plus
rien avoir dedans je ne pouvais même pas
installer une application pour installer
une application jeu devant supprimer 2
c'était insupportable donc quand votre
machine est trop petit 16 giga de
stockage comme celui là non extensible
bien évidemment le droit quand même pas
l'histoire
à ce moment là il faut un petit peu se
pencher vers la question de se dire est
ce que je dois changer de machine parce
que là c'est plus vivable voilà les cinq
cas que j'ai vraiment identifié dites
nous ce que vous en pensez à ce que est
ce que vous avez d'autres cas d'autres
besoins vous dit à ce moment là je dois
changer mon smartphone pour telle ou
telle ou telle raison
marc que le mois en commentaire parce
que ça peut être très intéressant et qui
manquent pour moi prendre votre tour et
puis pour les autres pour pouvoir
effectivement avoir d'autres cas
concrets attention je vous dis une fois
de plus ne changez pas vos smartphones
juste pour des envies mais vraiment pour
des besoins parce que au bout d'un
moment ça coûte très cher d'un point de
vue économique pour vous même si vous
passez par un opérateur de toute façon
vous allez le payer
c'est jamais gratuit tout spécialement
ou un autre et en plus du point de vue
écologique ça coûte cher parce que les
smartphones commencent à se recycler
tranquillement mais il ya encore des
grands grands grande décharge avec plein
de smartphones de partout ça crée une
pollution donc il faut quand même être
raisonnable là dessus alors c'était
l'instant l'instant conscience mais il
faut en parler quand on parle
effectivement de changer son smartphone
il ya un coût écologique et un coût
financier et cinq ans il prend en
considération
bon et maintenant qu'on appareils de
changer son smartphone qu'elle produit
vous ferez un oui est ce que vous êtes
tenté par les nouveaux produits de cette
année est ce qu'il y en a certains qui
vous font de l'oeil
est ce que votre smartphone vous l'avez
depuis longtemps dit que moi parce que
ça c'est vraiment intéressant de se dire
depuis combien de temps vous avez votre
smartphone sk des records de longévité
des records de durée - le mien ça fera
bientôt deux ans d'ici quelques temps
que je
et pour l'instant il fait encore la
faire mais quand je regarde un peu ce
qui se fait en terme de vidéo ailleurs
pour moi j'ai beaucoup besoin de vidéo
en mobilité jeu pas toujours mon gros
boîtier avec moi je me laisserai bien
tenter mais une fois de plus ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent donc marquer moi tout
ça en commentaire bien évidemment je
vous invite à rester connectés à vous
abonner parce que vous allez voir on va
parler beaucoup de choses pour vous
solutionner vous faciliter la vie du
point de vue de votre consommation de
smartphones de tablettes ordinateurs de
teck
en règle générale vous allez voir il ya
plein de trucs cool et ça on va en
reparler très rapidement comme
d'habitude des années s'est désolé
pouces en marquer vos avis suggestions
commentaire d'ici là un dc ce qu'on se
revoie c'est à dire très bientôt portez
vous bien soyez sages fait pas il faut
soyons heureux et à bientôt ciao